well
[Music]
hello, 3 gonzález greet you with their brief
Spanish hope news for today,
Tuesday, June 30, nvidia energy reported
that electricity is back for everyone
on charleston mountain
while firefighters are still working
on the mahag fire that destroyed three  thousand acres
since the beginning of Sunday 38
fire units are trying to control it
so far they have been able to contain
5 percent of the fire
and continuing with the same theme they report
an electrical fire at the
hotel construction site near
the fire and rescue team  from las vegas
said they responded to a small fire
on the fourth floor they got it under
control luckily no one was
hurt nearby plans to open the casino in
october but their rooms won't open
until december the metro police
are investigating a homicide near the
journal i saw this happen  a little
after 4 in the morning near flamingo
and you lose the authority  they said that
two men found a body
in the bushes near the
burger and pp restaurant the victim
was shot and pronounced dead at the
scene if you have more information about
this incident please contact
the crime stop phone number is 70 23 85 55  55
and now we go through with the weather forecast it
will be hot for today with
temperatures above 90 degrees
we will stay around 100
for the rest of the week but for the
weekend we expect more heat with
temperatures reaching 105 degrees
than  have an excellent day I greet you
andrés gonzález and this is about the
informative of iu news now in Spanish
[Music]